you
[Applause]
so I'm sitting across from Pedro the
coyote the human smuggler in his cement
block apartment in a dusty Reynosa
neighborhood somewhere on the us-mexico
border it's 3 a.m. the day before he had
asked me to come back to his apartment
we would talk man-to-man he wanted me to
be there at night and alone I didn't
know if he was setting me up but I knew
I wanted to tell his story he asked me
what would you do if one of these
pollito Saur migrants slips into the
water and can't swim will you simply
take your pictures and watch him drown
or will you jump in and help me at that
moment
Pedro wasn't a cartoonish TV version of
a human smuggler he was just a young man
about my age asking me some really tough
questions this was life and death the
next night I photographed Pedro as he
swam the Rio Grande crossing with a
group of young migrants into the United
States
real lives hung in the balance every
time he crossed people for the last 20
years I have documented one of the
largest transnational migrations in
world history which has resulted in
millions of undocumented people living
in the United States the vast majority
these people leave Central America and
Mexico to escape grinding poverty and
extreme levels of social violence I
photograph intimate moments of every
day's people's lives of people living in
the shadows time and again I've
witnessed resilient individuals in
extremely challenging situations
constructing practical ways to improve
their lives with these photographs I
place you squarely in the middle of
these moments and ask you to think about
them as if you knew them this body of
work is a historical document a time
capsule that can teach us not only about
migration but about society and
ourselves I started the project
in the year 2000 the migrant trail has
taught me how we treat our most
vulnerable residents in the United
States it has taught me about violence
and pain and hope and resilience and
struggle and sacrifice it has taught me
firsthand that rhetoric and political
policy directly impact real people and
most of all the migrant trail has taught
me that everyone who embarks on it is
changed forever
I began this project in the year 2000 by
documenting a group of day laborers on
Chicago's northwest side each day the
men would wake up at 5:00 a.m. go to a
McDonald's where they would stand
outside and wait to jump into strangers
work vans in the hopes of finding a job
for the day they earned five dollars an
hour had no job security no health
insurance and we're almost all
undocumented the men were all pretty
tough they had to be the police
constantly harassed them for loitering
as they made their way each day slowly
they welcomed me into their community
and this was one of the first times that
I consciously used my camera as a weapon
one day as the men were organizing to
make a day labor worker Center a young
man named Tomas came up to me and asked
me will I stay afterwards and
photographing so I agreed as he walked
into the middle of the empty dirt lot a
light summer rain started to fall much
to my surprise he started to take off
his clothes I didn't exactly know what
to do he pointed to the sky and said our
bodies are all we have he was proud
defiant and vulnerable all at once and
this remains one of my favorite
photographs of the past 20 years his
words have stuck with me ever since I
met Lupe Guzman around the same time
while she was organizing and fighting
the day labor agencies which were
exploiting her and her co-workers she
work in a small-scale protests sit-ins
and much more
she paid a high price for her activism
because the day labor agencies like
Ron's blackballed her and refused to
give her work so in order to survive she
started selling and lattes or corn on
the cob on the street as a street vendor
and today you can still find her selling
all types of corn and different candies
and stuff
Lupe brought me into the inner world of
her family and showed me the true impact
of migration she introduced me to
everyone in her extended family
Gaby one Conchi Chava everyone her
sister Remedios had married on selma
who's eight of nine siblings had
migrated from mexico to chicago in the
90s so many people in her family opened
their world to me and shared their
stories families are the heart and
lifeblood of the migrant trail when
these families migrate they change and
transform societies it's rare to be able
to access so intimately the intimate and
day-to-day lives of people who by
necessity are closed to outsiders at the
time Lupe his family lived in the
insular world of the back of the yards a
tight-knit Chicago neighborhood which
for more than a hundred years had been a
portal of entry for recent immigrants
first from Europe like my family and
more recently from Latin America their
world was largely hidden from view and
they called the larger white world
outside the neighborhood getting ilandia
you know like lots of generations moving
to the back of the Arts the family did
the thankless hidden jobs that most
people didn't want to do cleaning office
buildings preparing airline meals and
cold factories meatpacking demolitions
it was hard manual labor for low
exploitation wages but on weekends they
celebrated together and with backyard
barbecues and birthday celebrations like
most working families the world over
I became an honorary family
my nickname was Johnny Canales after the
Tejano TV star I had access to the
dominant culture so I was part family
photographer part social worker and part
strange outsider payaso clown who was
there to amuse them one of the most
memorable moments of this time was
photographing the birth of Lupe his
granddaughter Elizabeth her two older
siblings had crossed across the Sonora
Desert being carried and pushed in
strollers into the United States so at
that time her family allowed me to
photograph her birth and it was one of
the really cool esteems as the nurses
placed baby Elizabeth on Gabby's chest
she was the family's first American
citizen that girl is 17 today and I'm
still remain in close contact with Lupe
and much of her family my work is firmly
rooted in my own family's history of
Exile and subsequent rebirth in the
United States my father was born in Nazi
Germany in 1934 like most assimilated
German Jews my grandparents simply hoped
that the troubles of the Third Reich
would blow over but in spring of 1939 a
small but important event happened to my
family my dad needed an appendectomy and
because he was Jewish not one Hospital
would operate on him the operation was
carried out on his kitchen table on the
family's kitchen table only after
understanding the discrimination they
faced at my grandparents make the
gut-wrenching decision to send their two
children on the Kindertransport bound
for England
my family's survival has informed my
deep commitment to telling this
migration story in a deep and nuanced
way the past and the present are always
interconnected the long-standing legacy
of the US government's involvement a lot
America is controversial and
well-documented the 1954 CIA backu of
our bends in Guatemala the iran-contra
scandal the School of the Americas the
murder of Archbishop Romero on the steps
of the San Salvador Church are all
examples of this complex history a
history which has led to instability and
impunity in Central America
luckily the history is not unremittingly
dark the United States and Mexico took
in thousands and millions actually of
refugees escaping the civil wars of the
70s and 80s but by the time I was
documenting the migrant trail in
Guatemala in the late 2000s most
Americans had no connection to the
increasing levels of violence and
community and migration in Central
America to most US citizens it might as
well have been the moon over the years I
slowly pieced together the complicated
puzzle that stretched from Central
America through Mexico to my backyard in
Chicago I hit almost all the border
towns Brownsville Reynosa McAllen Yuma
Calexico recording the increasing
militarization of the border each time I
returned there was more infrastructure
more sensors more fences more Border
Patrol agents and more high-tech
facilities with which to incarcerate the
men women and children who our
government detained post 9/11 it became
a huge industry I photographed the
massive and historic immigration marches
in Chicago children in detention
facilities and the slow percolating rise
of anti-immigrant hate groups including
Sheriff Joe Arpaio and Arizona I
documented the children in detention
facilities deportation flights and a lot
of different things
I witnessed the rise of the Mexican drug
war and the deepening levels of social
violence in Central America I came
you understand how interconnected all
these disparate elements were and how
interconnected we all are as
photographers we never really know which
particular moment will stay with us or
which particular person will be with us
the people we photograph become a part
of our collective history Jenny kiss'd
Rolla was a young 8 year old girl whose
memory has stayed with me her father had
gone to LA in order to work to support
his family and like any dutiful father
he returned home to Guatemala bearing
gifts
that weekend he had presented his eldest
son with a motorcycle a true luxury as
the son was driving the father back home
from a family party the a gang member
rode up and shot the dad through the
back it was a case of make mistaken
identity and all too common occurrence
in this country but the damage was done
the bullet passed through the Father and
into the son this was not a random act
of violence but one instance of social
violence in a region of the world where
this has become the norm impunity
thrives when all the state and
governmental institutions fail to
protect the individual too often the
result forces people to leave their
homes and flee and take great risks in
search of safety yet IGAs father died
enroute to the hospital his body had
saved his son's life as we arrived to
the public hospital to the gates of the
public hospital I noticed the only young
girl in a pink striped shirt screaming
nobody comforted the little girl as she
clasped her tiny hands she was the man's
youngest daughter her name was Yeti
katralla she cried and raged and nobody
could do anything for her father was
gone these days when people ask me why
young mothers with four month old babies
will travel thousands of miles knowing
they will likely be in prison in the
United States
I remember yet eeka and I think of her
and of her pain and of her father who
saved
his son's life with his own body and I
understand the truly human need to
migrate in search of a better life
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]